hey Jeremy Jeremy from Texas the rich of
crazy how's he doing how's he faring
after his loss of his real bad real bad
and he's walking around this morning
like a widow you know what I mean like a
like a blegh honestly and it's like you
look at him you're like dude shut up
this is sir I don't know if he cried but
he was live-tweeting and I was thinking
about him I'm like your game is on
you're in a bar with a bunch of fans
you're certainly getting enough input
who thinks the live tweet and it's like
stupid life tweeting it's like all in
caps stop them stop them stop them stop
it's like 35 times stop them chiefs
touchdown Chiefs touchdown chief stuff
is like a three-year-old roses oh my god
Chiefs defense let's go oh my god Chiefs
defense let's go he repeats it over and
over again can't you just say it once
dude what's with the repetition why
haven't we gotta emphasize it did you
cry over the game uh yeah yeah yeah a
little
let me probably you did it you didn't uh
I'm not really cry but I did get to
teary-eyed like not on all out balling
but I was pissed like I mean he's a good
QB that's what's getting me through this
we're gonna have a lot of good years
with him he was great he's funny
yeah I'm gonna start getting emotional
let it out he he's a [ __ ] savior for
Kansas City man why we've always gotten
every other teams like sloppy seconds
and now we have a guy that you know Andy
Reed took this guy and made him [ __ ]
amazing and every cheat like I've waited
my whole life to see the Chiefs they've
never seen them what's wrong we do you
understand the [ __ ] spectrum are what
it really what is wrong my or the
straitjacket
god what happened to you hey you know
it's like I grew up loving this team and
I know like I want my dad to see this
Chiefs won another Super Bowl in my life
it's been 49 years 1970 yeah yeah yeah
and they didn't get it so close so close